on va rejoindre bixente lizarazu et
gilles alors allons nous faire des voix
la préserver alors on a installé une
planche de surf
c'est donc bio je vois je propose qu je
propose qu'on se fasse un petit plaisir
qu'on démarre avec bixente lizarazu pas
d'accord et après on aura la cata avec
gilles verdez bixente est-ce que vous
pouvez nous faire une petite
démonstration
regardez le gars est même beau gosse en
costume dénouant le gras sans les
connaissez bien aller sur la boutique
web
attendez la pâte au salut bixente
lizarazu c'est ou même quand ils tombent
lille et baudoin c'était comme ça se
regarde lucent et lizarazu c'est le
blond dans le sketch de gad elmaleh
c'est le gars même quand ils tombent
illégaux rien les pires des rares de 800
bon c'est vrai il a depuis on dirait des
fougasses le garçon décoller alors et
regardez vous aurez remarqué moi ce que
j'aime aussi c'est quand même la
personne qui manie le surf juste
derrière regardez il est magnifique
parce qu'il est très à l'aise à lui sur
la rai la faune qui donc à l' attention
on va envoyer gilles verdez est là bien
sûr
et bravo pour le blouson monsieur alors
attention et gilbert des forêts connais
sa tête s'il vous plaît le réalisateur
merci
super est ce que tous les
téléspectateurs
est-ce qu'on peut retirer les deux
chutes s'il vous plaît d'abord celle de
pichette et après celle de gilles verdez
pour que vous voyez un petit peu comme
quoi dieu on dit qu'on est beau dit
qu'on est tous égaux et bien non
regardez regardez attention c'est parti
regardez-la la chute de bixente regarder
voilà à bixente voilà il ya un moment il
sent que ça va pas aller rien voilà mon
boss tranquille le mec est bien et là
l'autre regarder sais pas si vous avez
vu chez vous il croyait que le surf
allait exploser la façon comme ça en
arrière genre y croyait qu'elle avoir un
truc qu'elle exposait unités il était en
angoisse bixente lizarazu qu'on retrouve
donc samedi à 16 heures 30 sur eurosport
dans frères de sport on va et vous
pouvez revenir à ce qui va rester la
balle revenait chez l'impression qu'ils
vont s'embrasser tous les deux